HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: I'm Yoshi.
I'm head of the Japan's
Business Development.
And also, I'm leading the
Go Global project as well.
So today, as we talk about the
Google Play is a great place
to distribute your
applications, then you
can choose whatever you want.
Like, publish your
application to everywhere.
But today, I would like to
discuss about the framework
of the Go Global.
It's more like I make the
framework on this slide.
Then I would like to
explain about each section,
about what we need to
think about to go global.
Then, after I explain the
Go Global framework, then
today, we invited the
gorgeous panelists today.
Then let's ask them about
their Go Global strategies.
All right, let's move on.
So first of all, select
the right market.
This is the most important
work for your strategy.
So we define the market,
established market,
like, we call matured market.
Also the Rising Stars
Market, which we call,
like, emerging market.
So for instance, the
established market
is US, Japan, Korea, Taiwan.
So they have many
the specific stuff.
But it's one thing, is there's
the high ARPPU users in there.
Then Rising Stars market
is monetize is through ads,
compared with the US and
Japan, their monetizing
is not that much.
But the user base
is going grow fast.
And also, the install base
is pretty growing fast.
So we separated two categories.
And also, each market
is different phase.
For instance, US has a different
face, like, different users,
preference, in Japan, also.
Korea has also the difference.
So segmented, it's different.
Also, each country, also,
they are different faces.
So let's see it at each market.
For instance,
like, Japan market.
So this is a top
ranking of Japan.
Then it looks like all
most Japanese [INAUDIBLE]
are in the top ranking.
Then Super [INAUDIBLE] here.
Then it seems like cute icon
is popular in the Japan market.
Then probably you put the
cute icons or cute characters
on the UI icons.
That would be good for
the Japanese users.
Then go to the Korea market.
Then seems like more
western developers
doing good on the top ranking.
Also, some cute characters.
But also, some serious
guys in top ranking.
That's the Korea market.
Then let's move on
to emerging market.
So this is Brazil.
So it seems like it's more
like western developers
doing very well in
the Brazil market.
And seems like "Clash
of Clans" and also
"Clash of Kings" and "Summoners"
as well, is doing well.
So that was kind
of like PvP stuff.
And also the import
market seems like.
So this is the Brazil market.
Then this is Indonesia.
It seems like similar
with the Brazil market.
But we can see more cute
characters, cute icons on here.
So it's more mixed
market, we can say.
I understand that those
markets stuff, then,
are decided where should
we go to the market.
So that's the select
the right market.
Then, next move on the
plan your approach.
So once you decided to go to
specific market like Japan,
or Korea, then you
need to figure out
how to fit that market.
So you should go with original
titles, original graphics,
go to that market.
Or change your graphics
to go to that market.
So that's the decisions
make you need.
But this is Asian taste
and Western taste.
So Asian taste is more
cute and a complicated UI,
but more efficient.
And then [INAUDIBLE] more.
And then western taste is
more like a landscape and more
simple UI's.
This is on a game.
Also, with the material
design, also, there
are group feed in everywhere.
So you need to localize
on your services.
But design wise, you don't
need to figure out that much.
Use the material design.
That's more efficient.
Then move on the next,
localize your applications.
Then don't just translate.
So this is most
important part as well.
So we defined a level one, two,
three, on the localizations.
So level one is just simple.
Just go to the marker.
Just quick, check
your application
to publish to those market.
Then see how does it work?
Then level two is
more go more local.
So for instance, like,
change your descriptions
in the local languages.
Change your screenshot.
Or change the icons
to the market.
Then change your
applications [? text ?]
in the local languages.
So that's at level two.
Then level three is go native.
They are more like
local relevant contents.
So for instance, put their
local relevant contents
in the UI application.
Like with Japanese
characters or Koreans
or event in that level three.
Then get more thinking
about their local users.
Then so that level is
level one, two, three.
So you can step up to level
one, to level two, level three.
Or you can go through level
three direct from nothing.
But we're inclined to check
your localized description.
Where is the native-check?
So if you don't
have a native-check,
from the local users, then
looks like this kind of stuff.
So graphics, OK.
Sounds like great.
But localizations, it
seems like question mark.
So that's from the
local user's point.
So we recommend to use the
native-check on that side.
Then make more graphic,
sounds, and localalisation.
It's great.
So that's a metaphor.
But that's looks like
from the local users.
Then this is my
recommendations to the stores.
So I supply the store listing.
Also, they're in-app games.
And this is Japan's,
Korea's, Taiwan, Hong Kong,
Brazil, Indonesia.
So we recommended the
language is what we need
to localize in for the users.
So this is one opinion from me.
But this is too obvious.
But make sure you are
going to that market.
Then localize the success
[? store ?] is the Musicmatch.
So they localized.
We discuss a lot, in Japan
market, about a Japan market.
Then they changed the
video trailer titles, then
icon, description.
Also the key images
on the screen shot.
They put the local talent
and then local contents.
Then put the local languages
in their screen shot.
Then they got a
ranking number one
in the music category
in Japan from 50.
Also, it's not only
for localization.
Also, I recommend to think
about the connectivity
in each market.
If you want to go
to emerging market,
then you need to figure out
the connection speed as well.
So for instance, APK
size might be smaller.
It's more good for
those emerging market.
Then after the download
and contents file size,
or data friendly, and then
also, the local pricing.
As Tim [INAUDIBLE] mention that.
So those kind of KPI
we need to figure out
If you want to go to
the emerging market.
So support local users.
So it's more easy.
But support local users
in the local languages.
That's an important
fact to go local market.
So this is the Korean developers
replying to users in Japanese.
This is important
for going global.
Then launch, test and iterate.
So as we talk about like,
experiments, A/B testing,
then acquisition channel
and also localizations.
This is like, keep
continue to doing.
So keep continue to improving.
So this loop is important
for the Go Global as well.
So this is a good
example for the arts.
So they did their experiments
on our Play Developer console.
Then we need an icon as the more
simple ones than 41% increase
of the download.
And also, this is
the game screenshot.
Then before they tried a simple
type of their screenshot.
Then they got good
numbers of the improved.
So that's the experiments is
important things for checking
on their localizations or
localized of the US screenshot
in the Go Global strategies.
So this is before,
after, finally.
So they put all good improved
the numbers of the result.
Then they changed their
screenshot in the after.
So leverage our
local market experts.
We have several
peoples in this venue.
So please reach out those guys.
Then ask your strategy stuff.
Right.
So that's my presentations.
Then
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]